[Music]
hey everybody
so oh my goodness yeah
[Laughter]
yeah we literally just got back from
seeing this movie like half an hour ago
45 minutes ago something like that we
went to the 155 showing uh honestly it's
it wasn't that bad um brian hackett
my boy i went to military school with
who works at hollywood he was bagging on
this pretty bad
it's not that bad though um it's it's
enjoyable um the original
fire starter movie was a low budget
sci-fi
horror kind of adventure flick
that's what this is uh they try to give
you
something new and then try to give you
some nostalgia there's you know
john carpenter does the damn
score for it and his son cody also yeah
they worked and it delivers it's good do
you know the score um
they made a lot of changes
uh
some of it i didn't like other ones i
just was didn't really care about the
changes that they made
it just it worked i guess um
it was just just they're just trying to
give you an enjoyable
movie under budget it's bloomhouse
yeah they did they did it okay yeah i
didn't be real strict with the story
and
it looks like they're trying to get two
movies out of this because it it didn't
really end
not my opinion
yeah that was the only i think that was
the only major criticism i had i didn't
mind so much because they did change it
quite a bit from the book so the story
is not the same
as the book which i kind of feel like
the 1984 movie was a lot more faithful
to the book um it's been a long time
since i read the book but i did like
read a quick plot synopsis just to
remind myself because it's probably been
like 25 30 years since i've read it
um so the 1984 movie which we might
actually watch tonight like re-watch
tonight and talk about tomorrow i don't
know we haven't decided yet but
um that one was a lot more faithful this
one made some changes and like you said
some of them i understand why they did
it some of them i was like man well they
probably shouldn't change that but i
didn't really
none of them like pissed me off or
offended me or anything like that but i
will say the ending is a little
anticlimactic that was the only thing
and i think maybe it's because
they're trying to like set up for
another one for another one or it's
gonna go into a series or a spin-off or
something like that like they were in
discussions i don't know if they're
gonna do it now because i feel like the
movie's maybe not doing that well
but
i don't know it's it's weird because it
seems like
critics it's you know it's kind of like
15 percent positive reviews whereas
public is kind of more like half and
half yeah um which is about right i kind
of feel like now i will say that i liked
this i think i liked this better than
you remember back in i guess it was 2019
that they did the pet cemetery reboot um
and they changed a lot from you know
from the book in that one too
i think i liked this better than the pet
cemetery review yeah
it's not as good as the director's cut
of dr sleep
um
which you know that kind of goes without
saying doctor asleep had a [ __ ] huge
budget
but you could tell that this is in the
same stephen king universe yeah as dr
sleep and you know
the shining and that kind of stuff you
know if you when these books all came
out
about when we were kids when these came
out
king was putting out some good [ __ ]
books and they were about
paranormal phenomenon he i he he knew
what he was talking about he got in with
some people who were
parapsychologists because
he describes
things that do exist you know and that
parapsychology was looking at him he
describes them pretty accurately
uh but then he blows them out of
proportion of course you know you got to
make it bigger and better in hollywood
and
what would it be if you really could
start fires with your mind
which uh i'm convinced can happen it's
just poltergeist activity which i've
seen that
uh just tell it's just uh psychokinesis
um instead of moving the object you're
just speeding up the molecules until it
gets hot enough to [ __ ]
something
catch on fire and then once it's on fire
it would just it'll just burn
now
there's some
a couple things decisions that they made
in this movie that [ __ ]
irked me
her dad
and then you find out later on she also
has the ability to to psychically
dominate a person
which is that exists
it's called mentalism or hardball sales
tactics okay which they work and
propaganda all this [ __ ] works as long
as you're not real aware of it they just
keep asking you questions and filters
all right so anyway
they have the ability to push people
mentally
and in this one the [ __ ]
the paranormal uh police or what do they
call them the uh [ __ ] the shop yeah
although they don't do they call it in
the shop in this movie they just call it
dsi i know in the book they just called
it the shop but in the in this this
movie it's dsi in the book they were
kind of a company that was contracted by
the cia to
find people that had paranormal
abilities and try to figure out
what to do with them you know [ __ ]
can you use them and they were making
drugs that were getting people to
actually
exhibit these things
this phenomenon back in the 60s
mk ultra kind of stuff there's a
historic there's a history behind all
this the us and the soviets were
interested in this they actually had
psychics they were working with there's
project stargate which that was a
reality
so that's kind of what they're talking
about but
it was a a company that they had
contracted
to deal with these people kind of like
somebody x-men actually when you think
about it but anyway um
it's [ __ ] stupid they have these
[ __ ] contact lenses to protect you
against mind control [ __ ] dumb okay
which yeah
i was sitting there thinking well that's
probably like a dumb idea yeah but i
liked the idea behind why you would have
that because like dsi who have
apparently because they were the company
that
uh you know gave them the drugs in the
first place and were studying the [ __ ]
that happened so you'd think that after
all this time maybe they have some then
they would have some way of protecting
because they know like about all of
these powers that people have so you
would think that so yeah the contact
lenses was a dumb idea but
i get the idea behind it like why they
wrote that in there i would have put
something more plausible like they were
injecting some kind of drug into
themselves that made them more resistant
to psychic force against them that i
could might be able to buy but just
blocking vision
nah i don't think that'd work okay um
the other one
that pissed me off
is that
they put on flame retardant silver
suits
to protect them against the flames that
that girl could make
it's clearly stated in the book and it's
clearly showed in the movie
that it that it was not a ball of fire
that was hitting you she was agitating
your molecules deep inside your body she
could start the fire inside you
they could they could put a [ __ ] five
foot square block of concrete in front
of her and she could stare at it it
would get so hot and start warping the
room and then
explode in a bunch of [ __ ] molten
rocks
okay putting on a flame retardant suit
it wouldn't work
they shouldn't have even thrown that in
there they should have made her a lot
more dangerous because then they go
ahead and they say you know if she could
accelerate these molecules and start
fires why can't she rip them the atoms
in those molecules apart because if that
happens she'd set off a nuclear a chain
reaction
which they do mention in this movie and
they and they mentioned it in the book
in the original film so they've already
said that that's a possibility that she
might be able to do that so what the
hell the [ __ ] flames why didn't even
[ __ ] think of that you know what i
mean it just i just thought that was
kind of cheesy it made it look like
that ability would be easy to foil and
it wouldn't be
yeah like i said i get the idea behind
it just because
you don't want this supposedly like
shady top secret government thing that's
been dealing with this for a long time
to seem like they have no defenses
against [ __ ] that they've been studying
but yeah they probably should have
workshopped it a little bit more to make
it like a little more
plausible the book and the first movie
had a more plausible means of control in
them
which they left out in here how they did
it in the other in the book and in the
movie is they
basically kind of came at them and
gained their
uh you know in a ruse and they would
shoot them with some kind of
tranquilizer dart and knock them out and
then they'd start doping them up with
these drugs so they couldn't use that
ability
that and
that's in the book
and they don't get into that in this be
and i think the reason why i don't get
into that is because the flow of time in
this movie's been time compressed
they get attacked the mom gets killed
they go on a [ __ ] run [ __ ] happens
and it all seems like it's just
a couple of days yeah like not that long
yeah the book goes over a period of a
couple of years
so it was time you know there was enough
time to keep the dad
doped up so he couldn't with that drug
so he couldn't use his abilities i think
they gave him a bunch of heroin too
didn't they didn't have him on heroin i
don't know they kind of neutralized him
they were using him as a as a tool to
control the
the girl keeping her dad alive but the
story's significantly changed and it's
then time compressed to be kind of more
like a
more like a paranormal horror adventure
but there are some things about the
movie that i really like they made
the girl what's her name again um
charlie charlie
it made charlie kind of a little bit
darker she
yeah she they made her like slightly
less adorable yeah i mean she's still a
cute little girl but they made her a
little bit more
uh morally gray i guess
you know what i mean
a little less sympathetic
yeah was a little bit more like carrie
towards uh after kerry started [ __ ]
killing people kind of like that yeah
um a little bit
which that's in the same universe and
charlie's mom
had
psycho
psychokinesis uh
like carrie she was a person like carrie
well i liked too that they kind of went
into because i don't remember if they
did this in the original film or not but
you would think yeah um you know charlie
she was like the daughter of two people
that had taken this experimental drugs
and they had powers so the dad had the
push and the mom had telekinesis
and so
charlie has like the pyrokinesis but she
also has like slightly uh she can also
do the push and she can also do
telekinesis like to a lesser degree
which like i said makes sense because
that would be like yeah and it makes a
lot more sense it kind of updated that
pyrokinesis is telekinesis it's the same
ability yeah uh it's just a different
manifestation of it if you look at
poltergeist cases some of the
poltergeist cases involve spontaneous
fires it's that's all that's what it is
it's rspk current spontaneous
psychokinesis except they can
consciously kind of control it although
her mom wasn't that good at it evidently
well because they explained that the mom
but she had been trying to like suppress
it she didn't want to use it yeah so
because i think even rain bird says that
like when he comes there he's like oh
you're out of practice because she can
still kind of throw [ __ ] around but her
aim was like [ __ ] yeah because she
hadn't been doing it for a long time
right um you know because again it was
it was kind of a thing which you know
they got into in the movie where you
know she was afraid it would like get
out of her control and she would end up
like hurting somebody so she was trying
like not to do it yeah and they show the
they show the experiments that created
the parents kind of like in a flashback
sequence during the beginning credits
yeah putting credits which i liked it
and it had a good carpenter kind of
score like it almost sounded like
something out of them
i don't know blade runner [ __ ] or
something like out of the thing and
they're showing like old video of what
happened you know people tearing their
eyes out and going [ __ ] crazy you see
the mom and the dad that created charlie
were like some of the few people that
survived it the other ones went [ __ ]
nuts yeah they went all russian sleep
experiments yeah
[Laughter]
and they they selected them for
basically being college students that
didn't hardly have any money and didn't
have any family that way if they came up
missing nobody you know there wouldn't
be lawsuits and [ __ ] and that's that's
they were both selected because
they were orphans
yeah yeah they kind of went into that
because yeah uh victoria the the mom
like she said her parents were dead and
then uh he didn't have a yeah he didn't
have parents he said he'd grown up in a
group home yeah so apparently he didn't
know who his parents were so and they
were like why are you asking all these
questions about our parents you know
what i mean but i did like the way they
had that compress like it's kind of gave
you an idea of what they went through
just like during the credits and but
they didn't really have to go super into
it like you got the idea
so i think that was good the way they
kind of like shortened it but i thought
it was like interesting if
it was an interesting choice to do
because you know how in the book and in
the 1984 one
they actually kidnap charlie right and
then i mean they kill the mom and then
they kidnap charlie and they take her to
the thing and then she
and then rain bird like befriends her
pretending to be a janitor yeah
and they didn't do any of that in this
yeah they changed the whole rainbow
story in this one like rain bird she
pretty much knows immediately that
that's like a bad guy that's the guy
that killed her mom yeah and that's the
guy that's coming after them and at no
point
does charlie get taken into the shop and
experimented on right at no point does
that happen at least not yet i think
that might happen in the second movie if
they do that they do a second move the
way it ended they're definitely
that was not an ending
that was a set up for a sequel
that's how that [ __ ] it did yeah it
didn't kind of seem like that that was
not an ending not really
um
so i i think the story was is only half
told if they make another one um but
which
why not
why not if it makes its money back and
make the profit you know i wouldn't yeah
i'm honestly i'm not really sure like
how much this costs to make it's
blumhouse so they usually try to keep it
under 10 mil i don't know how much this
costs if this costs more than that um
it didn't do i think they were
projecting five to seven million to make
the first weekend and i think it made
four so it's slightly underperformed
but i don't know they also released it
to to peacock the streaming service yeah
um so you could watch like
simultaneously so um i don't know so if
it does well on there like i said
blumhouse they they tend to like make
stuff that's lower budget so it it takes
a lot less for them to like make and
honestly they've made sequels to movies
way [ __ ] worse than this that's for
sure yeah
and uh
not to say it's bad it's not i didn't
mind it no it's what it's it's enjoyable
it's pretty good um
some people are
disappointed because it's not like
the first one but look the first one was
a [ __ ] low budget kind of piece of
[ __ ] too just it was one of the better
pieces of [ __ ] and we watched it a lot
and there were things about that first
one that was kind of charming and it is
a fun movie to watch
but a lot of the movies that are
legendary today low budget pieces of
[ __ ] they just did well
like scanners i put this over like cool
scanners did [ __ ] it's a little budget
movie but it was just a great movie you
know great to watch fun but people of
the day saw that and they're like yeah
[ __ ] that
but it's aged real well because you were
kids when you were watching it and and
it did looking back on it it had a lot
of good ideas and
so i'd probably put this up here kind of
like you know along the lines of you
know [ __ ] the first one the first
fire starter and scanners and
[ __ ] uh what else was the other one
that was kind of like the old
i would say christine was better but uh
what was uh yeah i liked christine a lot
and i kind of feel like a lot of people
when they talk about like best stephen
king adaptations hardly anybody brings
up christine and i thought christine was
[ __ ] awesome and that was john
carpenter yeah this was kind of like the
original dead zone about the same kind
of budget same about the same kind of
quality but it's more modernized you
know dead zone might have been spent a
little bit more money
but they had walking in it you know and
he he carried the movie yeah he kind of
made that movie
i mean the wrestling movie was good
but when those movies came out they
really didn't catch a whole lot of
attention they
they made their movie on cable
and uh you know hbo and [ __ ] and then
later vhs
and uh
generations of people just watched them
and they just kind of stuck in the movie
[ __ ] horror scene so there's no
reason not to make a a sequel to this as
long as it makes this money back i'd see
it
i want to see where they're going to go
with it
um
we were talking about perfect but it's
not terrible either i mean it's it's i
would watch it i mean okay like on the
on the spectrum of stephen king
adaptations yeah okay this one's just
right around in the middle yeah i mean
think of all the terrible stephen king
adaptations sleepwalkers right dream
catcher right looking at you langoliers
langoliers that was pretty bad um yeah
maximum overdrive i thought was bad but
you know well that one was so bad that
it went around all the way around and
became awesome again
because it was so terrible but there
have been a lot of shitty stephen king
adaptations i'm just saying
um that this one is really not it's not
a fantastic movie but it's not terrible
either i mean i wasn't bored it was like
it was pretty entertaining yeah yes if
you're expecting it to be faithful to
the book it absolutely is not it's in
the same spirit as the book yeah uh and
some of the same [ __ ] happens but they
did change [ __ ] around like i said at no
point does charlie like go
to the shop where they like experiment
on her and [ __ ] like that and like have
her dad there that's it doesn't go like
that but like you said i kind of feel
like they were trying to
time compress it so it happened like in
a much shorter so there was more of like
a propulsive kind of yeah
yeah kind of pace i guess
pace more modern yeah because the one
from 84 although i like that one it's
not really among my favorite stephen
king adaptations but the one from 84 was
fine um that one was a little rambling
because it went on for a long time but
like i said they were trying to make it
faithful to the book and the book like
covers like a really long time period
this one was just kind of trying to like
keep it moving
which like i said i get it um i do like
that they actually we were kind of
talking about this on the car on the way
home i do like that they actually had a
a real uh he's actually not native
american he's canadian uh but a real
indigenous person playing rain bird um
as much as i love john c george c scott
in the first one yeah um
i will well the weird thing about that
is like i was like okay the original
1984 movie there was nothing
in the um in the movie that said that
rain bird had to be native american
so i was like other than his name they
could have like so they could have just
like changed it yeah
you know unless they could get an
indigenous actor they got george c scott
you know white ass george c scott so i
was like why didn't they just change the
character a little bit yeah to something
because it wasn't super important to the
plot you know what i mean they didn't do
that back then i know which is weird
because it would have been like it would
have changed pretty much nothing yeah um
also
we were wondering about this too because
like i said i thought i saw the 1984 one
probably two or three years ago so i
remember that pretty good but i haven't
read the book for like a really long
time although i did read a plot synopsis
real quick before we did this so just so
i could remember
was it not i mean rain bird in the book
and in the 1984 movie it was pretty
heavily implied that he was a pedo oh
yeah
yeah now they kind of implied in this
one too but i think not as overtly
there's like a couple lines in there
where it sort of implies yeah i haven't
read the book in a long time i and i
remember
maybe about half of the [ __ ] that he was
talking about
when george c scott was doing it
in general the way i remembered it is is
that
he wanted to take the girl
he was in love with that girl and he
wanted to make
make that girl
she's like what seven or eight i thought
she was 10 but i couldn't remember how
old she was in the book because they
might have made her slightly older for
the movie i'm not real sure so the thing
was is that he wanted to befriend her
and that he loved her and she wanted him
he wanted her to love him
and then once she loved him he could
kill her yeah and that was kind of
[ __ ] up and it was and that she would
could go into the spirit world because
he was talking about spirit world a lot
you know he was
he was i don't think he was he has an
abilities in this one all right which
i'll talk about in a second
he
from what i remember he wanted to kill
her at that moment so she could go into
the spirit world in like a state of
purity
and then
later on when he died he would be
reunited with her in the spirit world
and we're talking about the [ __ ]
universe of the shining and ghosts and
this is stephen king's world
so rainbow rainbird might know what he's
talking about he may not be crazy
maybe he you know knows about the spirit
world and
just like you know out of dr sleep
it turns out vampires are real they're
just not as you imagined them so
it was he was trying to do something
like that there was kind of a pedo
element to it but it was like spiritual
pedoism i don't he didn't i don't think
he said anything about having sex with a
girl
he just would love the girl he's going
to be like yeah so maybe not technically
pedophile like in the sexual sense but
pedophile in the sense that he's in love
with yeah children that's the way or
that one i don't think it was all well
yeah it implies that it's girl it's it's
it's you real young girls is that what
he's into
uh because they said they brought it up
this is this is a good case for you type
of deal
yeah it said that in this one too when i
was like oh i see what you did yeah now
my buddy brian says he didn't like this
rain bird he liked the [ __ ] george c
scott rain bird yeah he's here okay
that's just because it's george she's
got man yeah i mean oh i agree i love
george c scott yeah and somebody said he
was great in the changeling yeah the
changeling is actually one of my
favorite horror movies of all time as
crazy as that casting was george c scott
pulled rain bird off with this he did he
had the eye patch and the [ __ ]
ponytail yeah he was scary as [ __ ] in
there he had the gravitas and he had
voice
and so he was able to pull that off but
that was just him
yeah
you couldn't do that with anybody else
if they put some other honky
[ __ ]
i don't think it wouldn't have worked
so i think he got away with it yeah
so i think they did a good job of
casting with this rain bird that's kind
of how i kind of imagine what what he
might look like from the book
um
so and i think he did pretty good with
the material that that they gave him he
doesn't have a whole lot to do
some of the [ __ ] that the character does
didn't make sense to me he shot the cops
when he didn't have to
and then the [ __ ] yeah a lot of cops
get killed
and then the secret agents lock his ass
up and start treating treating him as a
criminal and there was just no reason
for him to do that
but they must have a bigger story arc or
something could for this for the sequel
that's only explanation it's just that
for a guy who's basically a secret agent
well you know how could he be so dumb
you know and they they asked him that
why are you so dumb you know why why are
you so dumb yeah
they didn't say exactly that but that's
basically what they said why are you so
[ __ ] dumb um yeah he didn't seem like
because i kind of feel like in the
original movie like george c scott he
was clearly insane yeah uh in this one
not so much like maybe he's insane but
you couldn't really tell what was going
on because he was a little kind of stoic
and well he's and he's a psychic
yeah he actually
yeah
yeah georgie's got in the original one
he didn't have i don't think he's so i
don't think so i've been so we need to
watch it it's been a while and it's been
ages since i've read the book so i don't
remember he had kind of like extra
sensory perception he could he could
feel where you were and find you like a
scout
and i what i did like about the movie is
that they give him a little bit of a
backstory in terms of
they show what happens before the
mission he's just a janitor
okay
and
they call him up on the phone and they
they asked to reactivate him because
we're reactivating you so he was just
living as a you know as kind of like a
nobody in a way
and uh they give him a whole new mission
and he decides to take it and
when he he meets the boss and he's like
you know they threw you away like
garbage but we're bringing you back you
know i'm i'm the new one in charge and
[ __ ] i'm putting you back on the job
which i like that to let you know that
he what he was doing before and that
they'd kind of thrown him away and yeah
it gave the character a little bit more
depth to know where he came from
uh i guess he had a bigger plan you know
killing the cops
put him on the wrong side of the law and
the agency turned against him but it
seems to be that's what he wanted when
you see the end of the movie yeah i mean
it really did seem like he very
deliberately did that
and i don't know why
that's what i'm saying the way the movie
ended i'm like they're setting us up for
a sequel
he did all that [ __ ] for a reason they
just haven't told us yet
yeah so that's yeah that was my only
complaint so if they don't make a sequel
then the end no then the end is just
gonna be like what okay yeah yeah but
because the end was kind of like
ambiguous yeah they're like a little bit
yeah so he won he didn't want he didn't
win but
not really because she could kill him
you know just
yeah i mean all she got to do is go
yeah she'd blow your [ __ ] ass up
right i was telling tom of the car on
the way home i said it's a good thing i
don't have that power because i would be
in [ __ ] big trouble i'd be setting
people on fire left around
because i hate you and i hate you and i
hate you
so just looking at it in the spectrum of
all the
king movies and reboots and everything i
put it around in the middle
yeah it's just it's very middling it's
like it's fine it's entertaining like i
said i was wasn't bored it actually went
by pretty quick like it seemed pretty
short yeah so i hated it but i i don't i
know i didn't i don't yeah i didn't
really um feel like super strongly i was
just like that was all right yeah that
was all right right it's not real
emotional i didn't yeah i didn't feel
like i wasted my time or anything like
that and as i said i've seen way worse
movies uh generally but i've seen way
worse stephen king adaptations way worse
way worse yeah uh so this is just a
cemetery was not as good as this
yeah i think now that i was thinking
about it um
this i think this was better than the
pet cemetery reboot from 2019 which they
also changed significantly from the book
uh if you haven't seen it um
you know in regards to yeah so yeah this
was like faster paced and kind of had it
had a good new retro wave sound brought
to you by john carpenter to kind of
[ __ ] take you back to give you a
little bit of nostalgia and coolness the
kids like it you know they did that [ __ ]
and it almost it was kids today yeah it
sounded like cross between you know
looking
you know [ __ ] snake pusking [ __ ] and
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the thing you know
kind of sound a little bit like that it
was good you know
and there was something about it too
something about it kind of made me think
of a [ __ ]
halloween three two
there's something kind of halloween
three about the dudes with the stones
and the [ __ ] robots and
you know i mean the secret agent base
kind of reminded me of yeah that for
some reason i don't know why just
i don't know danny rolling ghostface
says what was up with that female
agent's eyes shifting she had those
contacts
that's how they showed you that she had
the contacts and it it prevented you
from getting pushed yeah that's what
they were for so yeah that's why she had
them on because she was in there like
talking to him and she didn't want him
to like push her into some kind of
special contact that had
computer-controlled stuff in there so to
block the psychic
abilities i don't [ __ ] you know so
they couldn't control your mind
it
it doesn't make sense to me
uh but i wouldn't have done that
i wouldn't have bothered
i mean like i said i like the idea that
this
shop had come up with something to
counteract some of the people's powers
but i would have made it something other
than that yeah but it didn't bother me i
would have made it drugs because they
made drugs to create psychics
yeah that probably wouldn't be yeah it
could have been like an inoculation or
something like that yeah that yeah that
might have been better but i guess it
wasn't as visually cool right you know
because you get to see like the flashy
eyes and that's really cool um slasher
fred is talking about rose red honestly
i saw that back when it first aired
because it aired on tv i think it was
like a tv mini series and that was back
in what [ __ ] 2001 2002 i want to say
uh and i read the book as well and i
remember it being good but i don't
really remember a great deal about it
and honestly i heard somebody like
talking about it the other day and i
said [ __ ] i really want to re-watch that
but i don't know if it's like streaming
anywhere maybe i can find it someplace
and
and re-watch it because i remember like
really liking it it being like a
haunting haunting of hill house type
situation and then somebody's talking
about salem's lot yeah salem slot was
great aren't they remaking that aren't
they remaking salem's lot yeah evidently
according to tila
that's yeah i thought they were which
that's that's okay they're made for tv
salem's a lot [ __ ] remastered for
[ __ ]
hdtv it's [ __ ] great yeah i think
it's on um i think it's on um shutter at
the moment saw the uh trailer for the
new cronenberg flick it looked [ __ ]
great i told you yeah i saw it my our
friend dimitri like sent it to me and i
was like oh my god that looks like the
corona burgess movie that ever
cronenberg i'm and i'm here for it it
looked like really good and yeah we saw
the trailer for that we saw the trailer
for the new jordan peel movie nope which
i also want to see that too now see it
says that the cronenberg movie is coming
out in june so maybe it is coming out
next month we'll see yeah but i told you
it looks cool right yeah yeah i'm
excited kind of awesome he downloaded he
says not that bad does not sound good is
it better than the original it's
different than the original yeah it's a
lot different it's different i mean as i
said it's it's obviously the same story
like it does follow some of the same
plot beats but the time is compressed a
lot more like you know they still kind
of go on the run the mom still gets
killed they still
you know end up at that farm and like
everybody comes to get them and [ __ ]
like that but
they that whole part with charlie being
befriended by john rainburn like
pretending to be somebody else like
trying to get her trust and stuff they
didn't do any of that
which as i said i get it because it
seemed like it was just set over
a few days or a couple weeks or
something like that rather than you know
the original movie i kind of feel like
spanned a few months didn't it it seemed
like maybe even longer brian's in there
saying this is the worst movie in years
and all this kind of that he doesn't
like anything from bloomhouse no blue
mouse is just low because he worked for
a different company
[Laughter]
it's not your company okay no
it was um
it was in the middle if you asked me of
stephen king
reboots and remakes in the middle you
know which is uh
passable passable i enjoyed watching it
uh just a slightly different take on the
story
um i don't think like i said
if you were to say that's the end of the
movie i would say yeah that wasn't any
good but no they're setting that up for
a sequel yeah that's only half the story
and i think that was really the only
thing that i had an issue with is that
they did kind of i mean the ending like
[ __ ] happened at the end obviously like
there was big like people got killed and
[ __ ] but the way they left it was a
little bit like
like a little bit ambiguous like huh i
wonder what that's like what's gonna go
on with that but
yeah so i don't know they they might
make one i do well like i said i don't
mind blumhouse because they have like a
really good business model where they're
just kind of like hey we're going to
make like 10 million horror movies and
then they just make their money back
some of them are shitty but i don't care
yeah you know most of them are like okay
like worth watching i'll watch them
actually isn't i think blumhouse is
doing uh that one the black phone which
i think is coming out next month that
looks alright too the one with ethan
hawk or uh ethan yeah ethan hogg
yeah who was in uh sinister which is
actually a really but that wasn't
blumhouse but that was i don't think but
that was like a really good movie too
sinister i don't think you ever saw that
did you i saw it a couple times
reading all this all the [ __ ]
fighting [ __ ] oh the fight
[Laughter]
no seriously it was i was just like
maybe just because
um everyone was like bitching about like
how bad it was like i said i didn't
watch any reviews
but i subscribed to a lot of horror
channels and you know how sometimes like
people have the the thumbnails and
they'll be making like a face yeah um so
you know i kept seeing like all these
horror channels with people's face like
yeah like that and i was just kind of
like
so that's how i got like the impression
so i was like expecting it to like be
awful and it really wasn't see he's his
[ __ ] brides and her saying see i hate
jordan peele too [ __ ] nope can you
think of a better title than that see
that's where you're gonna [ __ ] you're
gonna lose jetty because jenny likes
well somebody well somebody told me
maybe it was tila somebody said well
nope is actually like it's an acronym
for not of planet earth okay but but
also like no we're not having the aliens
for it i think i i think that's
hilarious honestly i think
[Laughter]
that one that one jordan peele movie i
liked and one where they were
underground that [ __ ] weird ass
[ __ ] movie
us that was weird all right i really
didn't understand it
i didn't really want to think about it
too much to understand it but it was i
didn't want to think about it yeah but
it was creepy okay
there was some kind of message there but
i don't know what a message was it was
just okay i just took it for what it was
just kind of [ __ ] disconcerting kind
of [ __ ] alien kind of weird horror
kind of just
i think there was a [ __ ] bigger plan
there but
you had to read into it it kind of
seemed like something pulled out of his
ass but i don't think it was it was
symbolic for some it was yeah um uh
brian asked did you guys see the sadness
yet i saw it uh tom didn't watch it and
i actually i recorded a review for it
today which is gonna go up on saturday
so gory he says it is it's very gory
like i said it's a [ __ ] bloodbath i i
enjoyed it quite a bit uh but yeah if
you're not into gore then uh
might might want to pass not it's not
the goriest thing i've ever seen but
is pretty [ __ ] gory yeah and it's
pretty much all as practical effects
god's saying top gun two looks looks
good because yeah it looks good to be
we'll see but from what they're showing
it what they're showing of it from the
trailer yeah the top down two look good
we'll see
yeah we're gonna go see that when it
comes out i think when is that actually
that'll be out uh
end of this month i think it starts may
27th i think so yeah like memorial day
weekend so not
this not next not this coming weekend
but i think the weekend after it starts
those people two more those last few uh
[ __ ] um mission impossible flicks
that he was in were [ __ ] great too
real good yeah i actually i actually
quite liked those but yeah i mean you
know
i don't know everyone's gonna like
yeah
i bought her for christmas this little
bitty plastic snowman that you put
treats in there and like when she knocks
into it like the treats fall out it's
not they don't fall out of his butt they
kind of fall out of his side
but i call it out of his butt
but uh she [ __ ] smacks she's like wow
she goes flying and it let's fly and
then like all the treats fly out she's
like woo treats everywhere and it's like
treatment
she's [ __ ] crazy
but yeah this i mean
i don't know i i guess because i told
him i was like look uh you know i've
been a fan of like mystery science
theater my whole life and i've watched
city movies my whole life if you make a
movie and it has like a coherent plot
and decent actors and you can keep the
boom mic out of the shot and you know
you can't see the zipper on the back of
the monster suit then then it's all
right you know what i mean i've seen
some really really terrible movies this
is not a terrible movie no no
it's a perfectly serviceable yeah
stephen king i think all the hate is
unjustified
yeah i think people have a little too
much
you know well you know how everything
has to be it's the worst thing ever like
i don't know why everybody has to be
like that it's seriously not it's fine
it's worse than cancer
according to bryce because it's bloom
house
all right he doesn't work for that
company
well like i said i've seen some
blumhouse movies some of them are good
that were that were really good and i've
seen some ones that were just that were
not that great they were just meh you
know what i mean yeah i don't think i've
seen a terrible one i haven't seen like
a bunch of them but they're either like
forgettable yeah they were
just kind of forgettable yeah which like
i said sometimes that's all i want i
just want to eat some [ __ ] snow caps
and watch a dumbass horror movie that's
fine yeah bloomhouse is just uh make a
cheap low budget
horror type movie
and you watch it and you don't ridicule
it or anything it's just it is what it
is and uh
they look a lot better than cheap movies
of the past
that's true they look a lot better than
what they used to look like imagine if
those things were made in the 70s they'd
be [ __ ] up like they'd be like giant
spider invasion
that's what i mean and that one's
actually like kind of entertaining it is
it's like you want to see like a [ __ ]
movie go back and watch something like
the blood waters of dr z and then get
back to me squirm
although squirms actually pretty early
with the [ __ ] worms and [ __ ] that's
that's actually not terrible that was
that was actually one of the better yeah
like shitty movies
um
i'm like one's like
like i said blood waters of dr z which
is just
an ugly middle-aged guy like in baggy
dumpy pants like walking around
pretending he's a mad scientist
it's uh it's something and it was shot
in florida so
and there's like [ __ ] where there's like
a swimming pool that's supposed to be a
swamp even though it's clearly a
swimming pool i mean you know it's [ __ ]
like that so i i've seen way worse
movies so i'm not gonna get like all
[ __ ]
i'm not gonna get my panties in a twist
about a movie just being like okay as
long as it entertains me for 90 minutes
talking about amityville the the
original amityville horror was cool back
in the day if you watch it now man that
thing looks like [ __ ] it looks
it's still i still like it but it's yeah
but i have just because margaret
kitter's in it and has a good cast
yeah
but no man [ __ ] and a good episode of
the [ __ ] of the haunting series of
television is actually like technically
a lot better
yeah i mean i still like amityville
horror but um it's nostalgia for me
because honestly i saw it when i was a
kid yeah when i was like seven or eight
and it scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
but it's like if you watch it now it's
like not scary at all
but not scary it just looks real bland
and it takes i honestly when we
re-watched it you know very recently i
was just kind of like wow not a lot
happens in this building no no so i said
it more happens in an episode of the
haunting
yeah it's haunting a summer wind
it's like one of the best [ __ ]
haunted house movies of all time and
it's a television just an episode off a
television series
where's that raccoon
no that's it yeah
yeah
uh somebody uh a long time ago said um
we'd probably like the fury i'm sure
didn't we do a review of the fury like
that's brian de palma right the one with
john cassavetes and he like blows up at
the end it's also about psychics i don't
remember that one yeah yeah we did i'm
sure we did a review of that because i
know we just watched it like a year or
two ago so we must have uh danny rowling
says is there any chance that we would
do an actual video on the film omega man
instead of just audio just wondering
because that would be epic what did you
talk about um because remember we did
the we did the omega man yeah a review
of it but that was like a long time ago
we had a video i could do a new omega
man yeah i have a [ __ ] even better
take on that because i've seen it so
many i've seen it a couple extra times
on top of that
and
kind of picked up some more subtext
there's a lot of [ __ ] subtext dude
you know what we should do yeah we
should do a whole like super episode and
we'll talk about last man on earth omega
man and the will smith one
why don't we do that like i'm legend
we'll we'll do all three adaptations
okay
like not maybe not this week but we'll
do it like maybe next week or something
all right
yeah brian said you did and i watched it
last week because you reviewed it the
fury yeah i was pretty sure that we had
done the fury it had like
what's-her-face that was in carrie not
sissy's basic but um [ __ ] what's that
actress's name the one that played sue
um yeah she's in it and it's like it's
kind of like
because there was a lot of movies in the
70s about kind of shady government sort
of things that were like studying
psychics like people with psychic
abilities so this was kind of about that
too this was kind of i think it came out
um
right around i don't know like maybe a
couple years i think it came out in
1978. so danny why do you want a new
omega man what is it that the old one
didn't give
i don't even remember what we talked
about on the earlier one but like i said
it would be cool because i don't think
yeah we've reviewed the omega man but we
haven't reviewed i don't think we
reviewed last man on earth and i don't
think we reviewed the will smith i am
legend either so it might be kind of
cool because then like we wouldn't just
be retreading the same ground then we
could talk about like all the different
adaptations and we could talk about the
book and that's i don't know that'd be
cool i think yeah maybe
yeah that that's a lot of material
yeah but i mean i don't know that i
could probably make a video like that
three hours long
well i know you could yeah
i'd almost rather just do them all
separately well maybe we could do that
like you know because we do three
matinees a week why don't we do that
then we'll do separate we'll do last man
on earth like a trilogy on sunday and
then we'll do a mega man on monday and
then we'll do that right that makes more
sense and then we'll do the will smith
one even though i didn't love the will
smith one but um
i've only seen it once and i remember
yeah
yeah
i didn't like the ending it reversed a
lot of the great things from the from
the uh yeah mega man well that's what
kind of pissed me off about it i was
just like well that's just kind of the
ending of it like negated the whole
[ __ ] point of the book yeah you took
it you took an awesome a movie that was
awesome
story-wise and then eliminated [ __ ]
most of the characters and just made it
a zombie movie no bad got
will smith pimp slaps the apocalypse
yeah
and then another thing that was really
[ __ ] bad
how can you be the omega man he wasn't
the last man on earth it was just in
that city
honestly the vincent price one is the
most faithful to the book just gonna say
the whole thing about the [ __ ] omega
man and [ __ ] i am legend
is that you are the last man on planet
earth yeah you're the last human yeah
the last everybody else is some kind of
a [ __ ] mutant or a vampire
yeah yeah
that's that's kind of they see you as
the monster
yeah because you're going around killing
them all right it has a lot of
there's a lot of philosophy in there and
a lot of it has to do with [ __ ] um
what do you call it
moral uh relativism is is
what it's about
and it's also very much about how man is
a [ __ ] evil monster and that um
you're destroying the earth the
environment and burning fuel and [ __ ]
like that so it's it's actually very
marxist
but it's not pro marxist it's
anti-marxist it's just showing you
that both sides see themselves as
monsters
that's kind of partly what it is if you
look at omega man the family is
basically antifa that's what they were
running around destroying [ __ ] going
after the [ __ ]
uh you know
this last [ __ ]
symbol of [ __ ] capitalism that's
really what what they're talking about
hugo says last man on earth is the best
one yeah i mean it is the most faithful
to the book gonna say and it's got uh
vincent price in it so bundy data asks
best werewolf movie we've gotten way off
track but that's okay yeah way off track
um that's okay we already talked about
the movie uh best werewolf movie howling
one pretty good howling one american
werewolf in london yeah um
dog soldiers yeah
ginger snaps yeah like ginger snaps
that was one with the cute girls in it
yeah cute werewolf i mean the original
wolf man's pretty good i mean that's
kind of like wolf was pretty good jack
nelson was pretty good
it was like a a a werewolf movie for
people in their 50s yeah yeah
[Laughter]
for middle-aged folks yeah
we're middle-aged folks yeah
yeah sebastian moran also said dog
soldier dog soldier is a badass i really
really like that that movie
there's not really a lot of good
werewolf movies i mean i haven't i
admittedly i haven't seen a lot of
werewolf movies but
i mean you can do right
yeah it is it's also kind of a dated
subject
so there's not many of them made
yeah that's true yeah i mean
and werewolves never had the [ __ ]
appeal of vampires and zombies just they
never
now
what was that one [ __ ]
underworld didn't that that had vampires
and werewolves in it it did and so does
twilight
yeah so you might say that those are
werewolf movies
hugo says benicio del toro's wolf man
was good yeah i remember seeing that in
the theater and i remember being good
but i can't but i don't remember that
much about it so i'd have to like uh
re-watch it because i do like monica del
toro a lot
um but yeah
yeah boomer werewolves exactly yeah it
is kind of like that boomer werewolves
all right we we gonna wrap it up yeah
all right so tomorrow
we're either going to talk about
whatever we'll decide we're either going
to talk about
the original fire starter movie from
1984 or
we're going to talk about the clive
barker adaptation rawhead rex okay
because we haven't decided we'll figure
it out because we actually watched that
again last night because i was like hey
what the hell i was looking for
something that i'd kind of seen before
that we hadn't reviewed but
yeah we'll we'll see how it goes if i
can find like the 84 i think the 84
firestarter is on
is streaming on peacock for free okay
and i don't know if we have that app but
i have to go and find it i have pluto
and i have to be obviously like the app
on the xbox but i don't think i have a
peacock if not i'll just rent it yeah i
think it's yeah it's 2.99 or 3.99 or
something like that on amazon prime all
right so we'll be back tomorrow for
another movie review so thanks for
hanging out with us this afternoon and
evening and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow